my name's John offered and
mark thank you for the introduction
earlier today so nuclear power faces
substantial hurdles if it is to be part
of the carbon free energy mix of the
future the long-term challenges of
nuclear waste coupled with serious
concerns about nuclear safety raised
urgent questions about continued use of
nuclear energy in this nation but new
technology and new policy approaches may
hold the answer to these questions and
that's why YC is delighted to bring
together this panel of distinguished
experts to discuss overcoming barriers
to a renaissance and nuclear energy
moderating this panel discussion will be
real Lucas Scarlett assistant professor
of engineering at University of
wisconsin-madison in the department of
nuclear engineering and engineering
physics she's worked on nuclear safety
standards for advanced reactor designs
and published articles on all aspects of
nuclear engineering welcome raluca all
the panelists and thank you all for
joining us Thank you Thank You Jared for
the introductions and I'll introduce the
rest of the panel professor rod Ewing is
a professor in earth science at Stanford
University and a fellow in nuclear
security at SESAC the center for
international security and cooperation
now and he's also the chair for the
nuclear waste Technical Review Board dr.
mark Peters is associate director of
Argonne National Laboratory just outside
Chicago he's a senior advisor to the DIA
and has given expert testimony to the
Congress on reprocessing and other
aspects of the fuel cycles and
non-proliferation and mr. Jim Brennan
and senior vice president of engineering
at Westinghouse Electric Company which
is a large company of two to three
thousand employees in eight countries
and supports nuclear fuel and safety
analysis in it and engineering for pwrs
pressurized water reactors boiling water
reactors as well as development and
deployment of new technology so I'll
will start this
no with a set of opening remarks from
each of the panelists and will continue
with with a discussion followed by
questions from the audience I believe
that there are note cards for questions
that have been passed around so as an
academic trained in nuclear engineering
it's difficult for me to have
credibility in the face of nuclear
energy skeptics that I am in fact a
nuclear energy skeptic myself and the
skeptics are right to some degree
because I've been trained as a nuclear
engineer and so this gives me a certain
trust in the nuclear energy community
and with that with that comes some
subjectivity nevertheless I think that
nuclear energy and all other
technologies should be viewed critically
we should continuously ask what kind of
a nuclear Renaissance we want do we want
a nuclear Renaissance why and very
importantly technologies should be
viewed in context and what I mean by
context has to do with the fact that
risk is relative relative there are
30,000 car crash fatalities a year in
the u.s. that's about three times the
population of the Yale campus and yet we
don't stop driving because it's
necessary or to be more specific because
we consider transportation an important
benefit and we don't have other
alternatives it makes no sense to take a
risk without a benefit no matter how
small that risk is and it makes no sense
to take a larger risk when lower risk
alternatives exist and so risk is
relative for nuclear energy the benefit
the benefit is energy and the risks and
costs fall in many categories say
50 environmental protection displacement
of communities social responsibility for
the management of spent fuel
non-proliferation national security
international security and so on so
let's take these risks and compare them
with the energy alternatives spend few
management for fossil fuel well the co2
is released to the atmosphere hum
mortality and Leighton mortality due to
the coal industry on some of these
criteria we can make simple judgments
but on some we cannot we cannot simply
sum up the risks for each character age
energy alternative in one single dollar
value or in a fatality count as the
ultimate metric nuclear energy has a
complex context and this is why we have
this panel discussion today now in
addition to nuclear energy the nuclear
technology being at having a very
complex context there are two other
features that are unique to nuclear and
that make the conversation even more
difficult and that's space and time so I
choose to take the risk of driving a car
and I directly benefit from that risk I
also feel empowered to reduce the risk I
by a safer car i drive cautiously i go
to the gym to make up for the impact on
my metabolism that sitting in an
immobile seat might have on me and on a
routine basis i forget about the impact
of air quality on the houses along the
freeways or on the bicyclists that pass
by and so I directly see the benefit and
for some reason or another I accept the
risks so I feel that I have a choice now
with electricity I don't have an
individual choice that the choice is
societal I can choose to connect to a
nuclear power plant while my neighbor
connects to a wind farm or even if I can
the risks of the nuclear plants still
extend to my neighbor so now instead of
trusting myself I need to trust society
and this makes the conversation complex
in addition to the complex context and
the distribution of risks and benefits
over large populations there is another
factor that we need to detangle well in
conversations about nuclear and that is
time when we evaluate the many
dimensions of nuclear power we need to
clearly define the time horizon spent
fuel is a challenge for which generation
today it's an economic challenge or in
light of the lessons learned
post-fukushima a safety concern in the
distant future it might become an
environmental concern when should this
issue be addressed with time scales of
decades technologies and caught and
costs evolved significantly so the
question of how and at what cost and
compared to what alternatives has always
to come hand-in-hand with the question
of when so lastly I will mention that my
research is in the area of advanced
reactors advanced nuclear reactors
specifically salt cooled
high-temperature reactors that can run
high efficiency gas turbines air
turbines that have the capability for
power peaking so in my subjective vision
of a nuclear Renaissance we will build a
global fleet of such reactors over the
next couple of decades motivated by
economics and an urgency to address
carbon emissions and growing global
energy demand while we do so will very
diligently work on improving safety
because
it goes hand-in-hand with economics all
the nuclear industry is regulated to the
same standards so the inherent safety of
salt cooled reactors make it easier to
achieve these standards with simpler
xande potentially cheaper of systems and
approaches we also very diligently work
on improved fuel utilization and hence
reducing the amount of spent fuel this
doesn't mean that we're putting fuel
disposals on them on the back burner it
just means that we're first addressing
the pressing issue of climate change and
creating a profitable nuclear industry
that can then reinvest in spent fuel
management non-proliferation safety and
security in the subsequent decades so I
think that so I think of all the
complexity of nuclear technologies and I
focus on one dimension economically
competitive energy production that can
displace fossil fuel because improving
one dimension is better than improving
none and I also think of several time
horizons and I focus on a successful
present that also supports a successful
future so I'll leave you now with a
quote by the poet Gertrude Stein that I
often use when I talk about analysis of
complex systems and interestingly enough
this poem was first published in the
Yale poetry review in 1947 so she says
in the conclusion to her poem titled
reflection on the atomic bomb she says
everybody gets so much information all
day long that they lose their common
sense they listen so much that they
forget to be natural so professor Ewing
thank you thank you if you don't mind
out stand because over the years I've
evolved so that I can't speak unless I'm
standing and I'll you know think about
this poem I'll try it i've been our
scientists i'll try to be natural common
sense because i'll be thinking a very
very simple view of my first point is
that I'm not so interested per se in the
future of nuclear age which I understand
to be the thrust of a discussion but
rather I'm very interested in
understanding to what degree nuclear
energy and address the issues of climate
change rising that per meters is the key
question I should also mention and it
was mentioned in my introduction I'm a
member of the nuclear waste Technical
Review Board I want to emphasize
right so my emphasis on is on thinking
first about the carbon cycle and the
introductory lecture did a very nice job
of introducing the nuclear community and
others to to this discussion all right
or I can sit on time all right so what
what I want to do is is just say a few
things about the carbon cycle
emphasizing things points previously
made first the carbon cycle is
complicated much more complicated than
this figure indicates but you have to
realize it varies over spatial and
temporal scales so at a million-year
scale something like the weathering of
rock plays an important role in our
understanding of how the carbon cycle
works of course we're interested in
terms of climate change in more recent
time periods also I want to emphasize
that the amounts of material gigatonnes
of carbon are really substantial you
know if you in the evening want to
entertain yourself you can calculate the
volumes of materials that we have to
dispose of so when we talk of of carbon
sequestration its startling when you
imagine the mountain of material that
that we have to dispose of and also this
large amount is growing rapidly I use
this slide of the carbon cycle from 2002
because at that time the estimate was a
little over five gigatonnes of carbon
emitted into the atmosphere today I
think it's closer to eight gigatons plus
del ten gigatonnes all right the message
here is that while we talk about a
nuclear Renaissance while we dream of
alternatives
we're losing ground so rapidly that some
of the alternatives become less and less
attractive so timely action is is
essential and then finally what we're
talking about today is taking a nuclear
power plant and replacing the fossil
fuel plant ideally first a coal-powered
plant with a nuclear power plant but
what we have to realize is that when you
do that you're not just not putting a
nuclear power plant in place of this
coal power plant you're bringing the
whole nuclear fuel cycle with you okay
and so a proper analysis a complete
analysis requires us to look at all
aspects of the nuclear fuel cycle in the
same way we consider co2 emissions from
burning fossil fuels we have to consider
all of the releases of radioactivity
associated with the fuel cycle now this
is a simple and typical representation
of the fuel cycle fuel cycle is a
fascinating item because with nuclear
reactions you have the possibility of
consuming and creating fissile materials
and so it's it's beautifully complex but
a point i want to make particularly in
terms of the timeliness of the nuclear
solution to at least a part of global
warming is that when we look at the fuel
cycle in the u.s. we don't have all of
the elements of the fuel cycle we have
Superfund sites though associated with
the mining of uranium we have enrichment
facilities we have fuel fabrication
facilities we have reprocessing or
high-level waste from reprocessing from
our weapons program looking at this
diagram the first thing i want to
emphasize is notice there's no geologic
repository okay this is typical of
nuclear thinking the nuclear communities
thinking and i'm part of that community
about the problem okay geologic disposal
the final site for the spent fuel is
often left until the end of the
conversation also when we think of
high-level waste from reprocessing from
our defense activities you have to think
about the Hanford Vittra keishon plan
okay remember for nuclear we need a
timely response okay so in two thousand
the year 2000 the contract was led at
Hanford for this vitrification plan the
cost was estimated to be about 4.3
billion years billion dollars and the
start date was 2007 in 2006 the contract
was renegotiated the start date would be
20 19 in the cost is over 12 billion
dollars this is a typical this is
typical of the fuel cycle for recycled
fuels mox mixed oxide fuel where we take
the plutonium recovered from
reprocessing and get it back into the
fuel and then finally reactor we try to
do this in the United States we have the
MOX facility under construction at the
Savannah River Site the cost is grown
from estimates of about 3 billion to 30
billion it's fallen behind schedule and
so on for the repository we can talk
about the difficulties with Yucca
Mountain the 30 years of effort and tens
of billions of dollars spent for whipped
by repository for transionic waste we
simply note that it's closed because of
a release of radioactivity very small
release but that release will cause the
Department of Energy to spend about a
half a billion dollars getting two
minutes so when we think about these
problems the thing that's most
interesting to me is that nuclear power
or any alternative energy resource has
to be available in a timely fashion and
timely means over decades up to 50 years
you can see already some of the delays
and facilities in the fuel cycle in the
United States and so what the image i'm
sorry to use simple cartoons but
that's the way my mind works we have the
carbon cycle for the globe for our
planet and the question is how large and
what type of nuclear fuel cycle do we
need or can we use to impact the carbon
cycle and given the scale and timeliness
that's a challenge estimates for
increasing nuclear power production
range from a factor of two to ten a
factor of two globally would mean
building about a thousand power plants
in the next 50 years okay does that seem
like a reasonable expectation because we
can't experience what we have
experienced in the United States we
can't experience it again that 20 or 30
or 40 years from now we're still talking
about doing the same things and waiting
for for the result once you tell me what
type of fuel cycle you want and how
large it will be then I can talk about
nuclear waste problems which are
essentially just looking at geochemical
cycles for radioactive elements and then
also I think we have to consider the
importance of weapons proliferation and
I would suggest that weapons
proliferation is an environmental impact
as important as the mortality associated
with burning coal or other fossil fuels
I'll stop there thank
Brennan I'll wait from the pull up my
slider thanks Jerry I'm pleased to be
here to discuss this important topic and
i can tell you fortunately very
fortunately at 17 i was not operating a
nuclear reactor as you may know
westinghouse is solely dedicated to to
the nuclear energy industry we are
committed to providing the existing
nuclear fleet with high quality fuel
maintenance and engineering services we
are investing in new technologies and
services to take plant safety and plant
performance to even higher levels like
to talk a little bit about our company
we were founded by George Westinghouse
who didn't did many things but one of
them was work with Nikola Tesla
pioneered the alternating current
technology that electrifies the world
today we have been involved in many
firsts within the nuclear energy
industry we developed the first
industrial atomic Smasher atom smasher
the world's first nuclear propelled
submarine the USS Nautilus and also
designed the first commercial
pressurized water reactor at shipping
port just outside of Pittsburgh today at
present we are constructing 88 p1000
plants that's our newest plant design
it's a passive plant design for those
are in China to in Georgia and to in
South Carolina and we have plans to to
build additional units in Asia Europe
and here in the Western Hemisphere we
are also developing new fuel designs
that are accident resistant today fifty
percent of the world's operating nuclear
power plants are based on Westinghouse
technology
as all of us know safety is the most
significant driving force within our
industry all new nuclear technologies
must take safety to a higher level along
with that to be competitive new plant
designs must reduce capital costs of the
new plants must reduce operating and
maintenance costs and our belief is that
a passive design such as the the ap1000
addresses both of those requirements
it's inherently safe and by using less
equipment and less systems for safety it
reduces capital costs and the long-term
maintenance costs developing new nuclear
technology is is a long-term proposition
you must conduct the necessary testing
programs perform intermediate design
meet regulatory licensing requirements
complete the final design and of course
construct the first first-of-a-kind
plant innovation in the nuclear industry
does take commitment and it does take
perseverance as an example I'd like to
walk you through the design and
licensing process of the ap1000 plant
and its predecessor the AP 600 it
started in 1985 with an epi and do we
program that sponsored light water
reactor concepts after a period of
evolution we were able to submit the AP
600 SAR safety analysis report to the
NRC seven years later in 1999 we
received the NRC Design certification
for the AP 600 we modify that design and
upgraded the plant to a thousand
megawatts and in 2005 received the NRC
certification for the ap1000 and this
year we will load our first fuel into
the Sandman plant in China so what does
it take to commercialize a nuclear
reactor today certainly takes
collaboration among among many entities
we need the collaboration with our
we need to understand what their
requirements war and and what the the
market is driving towards we need a
consistent government policy which which
has been a challenge and must have a
solid mission our mission for the ap1000
was to build a passive plant that had
inherent safety features you need to
understand your licensing path you need
to talk with the NRC you need to listen
to their concerns and you need to be
responsive to the questions that they
have you need to have collaboration
within the industry we worked with many
partners here in the US and and also in
Europe and Asia you must have cost
sharing agreements and I spoke of how we
work with every and the do e and of
course you have to have public
acceptance so and that's only driven by
a high degree of safety in your plant
design so we are working on additional
new technologies and new plant designs
that include sodium high temperature gas
reactors and fluoride salt designs we do
want to be the first to innovate the
next advanced nuclear plant technology
and in closing we believe nuclear is a
vital part of diverse energy future
commercialization is is a long path it's
it's one that we understand and we're
committed to we continue to explore new
technologies that will help our
customers generate cleaner safer energy
for more people in a better planet the
next slide that I have is a time-lapse
photography of our plant and China and
shows you the construction progress from
2009 through the end of 2014
okay thank you after my Peters so it's a
good morning so you're gonna have to
stare at me I didn't bring slides
because I just want to talk so just so
you have perspective I guess this is the
revenge of the earth scientists i'm also
an earth scientist who is part of a de
national laboratory system it spends a
lot of time thinking about advanced
nuclear energy technology from a from an
electricity production perspective
dealing with the fuel cycle and also
thinking about it from a sort of global
non-proliferation perspective so I'm
fortunate enough to manage a large group
of people that are gone who think about
that on a daily basis so just that's the
context with which I approach this
problem I don't National Labs don't make
policy but we actually spend a lot of
time with people who make policies
that's an interesting place to to be in
this world because the nexus between
particularly nuclear energy in the
nuclear fuel cycle and policy is a
really fascinating place but I want to
start with I would maintain you should
know that going through my comments that
when you look at the sort of our energy
future and if we're serious about
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
mitting the effects of climate
mitigating the effects of climate change
and also serious about energy security
from a domestic perspective and any
country if they're serious about energy
security everybody says this there's no
one option there's no free lunch that's
a true statement the quantitative
analysis shows that and i would put to
you that nuclear energy needs to be
needs to be a viable future option if if
we in the US and for that matter other
countries are serious about a future
where we do those that address those key
key challenges um so when I think about
the future of nuclear energy it's partly
captured in the title of this panel
there's there's there's challenges four
or five challenges many open how you
slice them that one has to think about
and it's important to know that yet I'm
a technologist I'm here to help well
there's some truth to that there
our advanced rd and advanced
technologies that can be developed that
can help to further address some of
these key challenges that face nuclear
energy in the future so I'm gonna sort
of march through those quickly and I
want to sort of give you a perspective
on a road map to the future and what
would it might look like um so let's
start with safety so we've heard a bit a
bit about safety I also want to make the
point that the this morning speaker
spoke spoke of Three Mile Island then
Chernobyl and Fukushima and and I'm not
an industry person but I've watched how
the industry and NRC in the US have
responded those accidents how the world
has responded to those accidents for
that matter and there's been I would say
that they've shown the ability to learn
from each of those accidents different
things have resulted just for your
benefit after three mile island that
there was the institute for nuclear
power operators it was created and then
after tree noble there was the world
association of nuclear operators that
was created those accidents occurred for
different reasons Fukushima is of course
for a completely separate reason and and
chairman farlam probably speak to the
NRC response to Fukushima etc and and
what's been the ramifications of
Fukushima on the on the nuclear power
industry in the US and worldwide but
there has been responsiveness and some
of those and part of that responsiveness
is involved the way we operate plants
but also there's been technology that's
come to bear way we analyze threats to
the to the to the design basis threats
etc either from natural or man-made
threats but also technology solutions
have come to bear to address that
security and when i say security i'll
separate security from non-proliferation
although they're linked i'll talk about
non-proliferation in a minute security
clearly in a post-911 world the United
States in particular responded in a very
robust way to thinking about okay in
that that really oh I think opened up a
whole new set of scenarios when we think
about potential threats to something
like a nuclear power plant um economics
I'm not an economist but a lot of what
we're thinking about in terms of is
particularly when we talk about advanced
technologies whether it be fuel cycle
related
or an advanced reactor for electricity
production the design features clearly
they have to be robust safe secure
efficient but there's also a lot of
research going on particularly the
National Labs thinking about putting
features in place that do all those
things but are also more affordable sort
of getting down the cost curve when you
talk about advanced reactors there's a
challenge with making them cost
competitive as well as you think about
commercialization of those machines down
the road um non-proliferation that's
that's a very it's a very complex
subject it involves two technical issues
policy issues but there's a lot of
research and development and technology
development that goes on to think about
how one could actually safeguard either
through inherent design features or
through adding additional sensors and
instrumentation so that one can actually
convince yourself that you're actually
as you took it look at global expansion
of nuclear power that within the
framework of monitoring etcetera that's
required no matter what you do you can
actually set up a robust system that
convinces I guess convinces us that
we're doing this in a safe and secure
manner and then finally a waste
management yeah thanks waste management
rod already talked about that sauce I'll
skip that so I've but I want to I want
to talk for just a minute about sort of
where we are today and where where we're
headed and one thing that hasn't come up
yet that I think is really important is
if you look at projections for the
current fleet of nuclear reactors and if
you look at say the Energy Information
Administration projections on the de
website or you look at Nuclear Energy
Institute projections you get out to 20
30 40 the existing fleet even with life
extension starts to retire and depending
upon there's there's assumptions
associated with this but it's a fairly
precipitous decline in nuclear power
production so we really need to start
now thinking about what do we get what
are the options for replacing that yeah
renewables need to grow no doubt no
argument we need storage and all those
things but i would put to you that
that's not going to take up that entire
that entire gap so we need to start now
thinking about what the reactors will
look like
then you heard a little bit that for
about that from Westinghouse there's a
lot of work that can be done between the
universities is being done between
universities labs and industry and that
needs to just be scaled up in my opinion
and accelerated because the timescales
that we're dealing with to be able to
get to that salute get to get to those
those designs that are ready for
commercialization are significant and we
need to start now and there is work
going on but I would argue it needs to
be accelerated to address that challenge
and then finally on the fuel cycle rod
already talked about it maybe we can
deal with it during the discussion I
sort of talked about it a different way
there's two end members you either go
through what I'll call an open or once
three once through cycle where you mine
uranium you generate electricity you
take the spent fuel you stick it stick
it under ground in geologic geologic
repository that's the current to be
clear that is the current policy the
united states to do that in fact you can
also go to a close fuel cycle and member
being your recycling all the material
still need a repository but you're
recycling the material and there's we
can talk maybe about what's going on
worldwide in that space so there's but
the paw of the policy enables are really
important to that but there's a lot of
rd that goes into thinking about how one
closes the fuel cycle regardless of
option that you choose so i just want to
leave you with the fact that there's
there's this nexus of science technology
and policy that's so vitally important
to thinking about this this topic and we
need more people thinking about it from
both sides and doing it more in
partnership to really push us ahead and
I'll stop there
thank you very much for the
introductions I want to remind everybody
too if you have questions to write them
on on note cards and I'd like to start
the discussion with the question of
defining nuclear Renaissance so what is
nuclear renaissance in your vision and
what time what time line does such a
nuclear Renaissance have Jim would would
you like to start well I think I know
when we talk of the nuclear Renaissance
I think it certainly involves wide
acceptance of of deploying additional
reactors it means investment in
additional reactors I think it means
that the the marketplaces is is ready to
build new nuclear new nuclear units
relative to the time frame I think a few
years ago before before gas prices came
down and before Fukushima we believe
that we were at the beginning of a
nuclear Renaissance there were several
plants that were operating their units
we had received a number of new plan
orders and then natural gas prices came
down nuclear power right now I think if
you talk with many of our customers both
the United States and internationally
you know that's the the competitive
nature of the energy industry is is very
strong and and some of them are
struggling so I think those are all
factors that that contribute to a
nuclear Renaissance we actually believe
that we were starting one about ten
years ago and then some factors came in
that that really really turned that
around so so how would this Renaissance
be different from 40 years ago when a
lot of plants were built Wow or is it a
reiteration of 40 years ago well I don't
know if we'll ever get back to to where
we were 40 years ago but and certainly
there are other alternatives to
to energy than what there was 40 years
ago I think we are we do realize that to
achieve diverse energy requires more
than just nuclear power but I think
nuclear power can play a significant
role in it so so in your vision the
nuclear renaissance is driven by
economic competitiveness and demand
market demand that's that's certainly a
key aspect to it I think there's that
there also has to be public acceptance I
think there has to be govern acceptance
and I think there has to be strong
government support and policies to allow
nuclear Renaissance to take place mark
would I guess what at the risk of
starting out negative i don't like the
word nuclear renaissance actually but i
think one thing i would add is the we
need to think about this globally right
this isn't this isn't just about the
United States I would argue there's a
global expansion of nuclear power it's
just not in the United States China's
building them and Westinghouse was very
active there but you're starting to see
a lot of countries start to step up and
actually start to build either plan to
or already building plants the UAE
Vietnam Jordan so it's it's really it's
different than it was 40 years ago
because you're getting a lot of other
countries at the table then we're during
that original if you want to call its
so-called Renaissance and so to me it is
happening globally it's just maybe not
happening in the US and there's a
variety of market reason economic
reasons for that but I would argue we
have to start building as I said we have
to start building over the course of
decades if we're serious about
addressing some of the challenges and
its global being driven by the energy
global demand or are there other factors
that that come into play at the global
scale I'm not an expert I'm a lot of
it's a lot of it's just the what's
called the developing world I mean
energy is so closely linked to quality
of life and economic competitiveness and
all that you said that yourself that I
think there's that you have to produce a
lot of energy and nuclear is one option
i mean but in a lot of those countries
they're doing everything they can to
generate energy not just not just
nuclear in other cases you know the
ayee makes I think makes it very
interesting decisions relative to why
they go to nuclear there's there's
specific things they're trying to do
with these out but also protect the oil
gas reserves that they have so there's
different reasons but the bottom line is
it's happening and I would say from the
final thing I would say from the US
perspective is we better be at that
table because if we're not at that table
from a security non-proliferation
perspective that that's a big problem
and that's a really interesting
dimension that comes into play Rob do
you care to comment or give us your
vision of the nuclear Renaissance if you
like that term so i will just agree with
mark I I don't like that term I live
through the brief Renaissance and say
around 2005 and what happened then was
there was great enthusiasm for all
things nuclear I was a member at that
time of the faculty nuclear engineering
faculty at the University of Michigan
and my colleagues were dreaming of a
wide variety of advanced reactor
technologies and it was all very
exciting and then it's come to a little
bit of an end but I want to come back to
my main point we don't need a
renaissance of nuclear power we need to
reduce co2 emissions and so that may
mean in fact using the technologies we
have today building power plants without
the most advanced technologies but
rather power plants that we know work
and have been modified in a way you know
to a certain extent to work a bit better
but the main issue before us is not a
renaissance but to reduce co2 emissions
so I'll take a question from the
audience is there a global policy agency
for addressing waste processing
transport and disposal which countries
the furthest along and approving a
central repository so there's really no
I was that to me I guess yeah there's
there's really no global agency although
the IAEA does have activity
is related to repository characteristics
and in particular to evaluating the
safety of repositories over long periods
of time terms of other countries I think
this is a very important question
because at a fraction of the cost other
countries have moved far ahead of the
u.s. not only in terms of developing the
technology licensing the repositories
but also in terms of public acceptance
and I think by and large in the US we've
ignored those lessons so probably
Finland will be the first country to
have a repository for spent fuel
followed quickly by Sweden both of in
recent years made major progress in in
their their efforts France is moving
ahead that I think commendable right and
so on and how how does how do we decide
how urgent this problem is to address if
we if we look at the urgency of climate
change and we look at the urgency of
addressing the management of spent fuel
how do we decide their respective time
scales and prioritization so the urgency
is in my mind replacing fossil fuels
with other sources of energy okay the
urgency related to the accumulating
spent fuel in the United States you can
take two very different views one
following the rulings of the NRC one can
say well we can accumulate this fuel on
site or at a consolidated site safely
over periods of decades to hundreds of
years and so the sense of urgency might
be lost in that statement from my view
there's a real sense of urgency because
failure to solve the problem passes it
on to future generations and I don't
think that's correct but also there's a
urgency because many of the decisions
were making today on react at reactor
sites where we're storing the spent fuel
will affect the difficulty of disposing
of it longer term examples would be how
many fuel elements are do you put into a
dry storage task how large is that cask
can it be transported can it be lowered
down the shaft of a repository do you
both the dry casks shut so that you can
unbolt them and enter it or do you weld
them shut condemning you then to a more
difficult process of cutting them open
so we're making a lot of decisions today
that will have a profound effect on our
ability to dispose of the waste our
affect the cost of disposing of the way
so I think there's real urgency and
arriving at a solution that we
understand and that we can pursue and
bring to completion so how do we go
about comparing the two urgencies is
there is there a way to to understand
are there other decisions that are being
taken with regards to spend nuclear fuel
that are that then have an impact on the
rapid expansion of nuclear technology
mark do you let me make sure are the
decisions being made today that would
affect a nuclear future really is are
they decision me being made today with
regards to spend fuel that then in turn
affect the nuclear Renaissance to watch
it grow so nuclear well I would say I
mean let me start by saying what rod
said about intergenerational equity and
leaving it for future generations and
also the fact that we're making
decisions today that could that would
spend fuel and storage that could affect
the way we think about disposal I agree
with both those
points wholeheartedly so I guess what I
would add is is that I think the lack of
this is a now us domestic statement not
a not a as rod said other countries are
on a path that the lack of a coherent
path forward on dealing with used fuel
in the United States is complicating the
conversation about nuclear energy as a
future option it's and and I would argue
if you got that Paul and it's going to
take a long time to get there even if we
decide to go build a repository it's
decades so we have to get back on the
path of having a coherent policy to
start that work over the decades so that
we could enable nuclear is a future
option I would argue Jim do you want to
comment I think it's been well stated I
think when you talk about the expansion
of nuclear and nuclear power the
conversation inevitably does come back
to to the waist question so resolving
the voice question I think restores
public confidence in the whole fuel
cycle for nuclear so I think it's a key
part that needs to be resolved I agree
with what the other panelists have said
so mark I want to go back to what you
said about policy and this is this is a
question from the audience what what are
the policies that need to be enacted for
addressing carbon carbon emissions
reduction oh I'm am i I'm not you're not
going to get me to go too far with
specifics but I to me there's got to be
a global framework to let's say manage
manage carbon price on carbon whatever
you want to say that you've got we've
got to do something that's a global
framework and to me if we do that that's
the right thing to do how the u.s.
implements that is I mean you've got the
EPA clean power plant proposed clean
power plan out there now I'm not going
to know it's out there you had
waxman-markey in previous Congress that
was cap and trade cut attacks there's a
lot of different ways to do it but to me
a quote price on carbon is really really
important to drive the right behaviors
and in the realm of nuclear technology
are their nuclear technology specific
policies that
um that should be discussed I well how
about how about let's just start with an
energy policy that would be that would
be a good start and then if we have an
energy policy in the nuclear space in
particular having a policy related to
use fuel management a coherent policy
that we're actually on the path to do
something and implement would is key
we're looking can I just follow up on
that quickly because there was another
question what about standard it could to
be a policy that helps to standardize
new nuclear reactors that are being
built in the US or is that something
that will just happen as a interaction
between academia government and private
sector to standardize new reactors
design for new nuclear reactors in the
US okay well I you know I think there is
a tremendous amount of regulation
currently to how how reactors need to be
built how they need to be operated so
when you talk about standardization I do
think you need to be a little careful
because they're there are different
ideas out there different thoughts on on
what is the optimum reactor design and
we're continuing to look at that when
you do build a plant and this is what we
are trying to do I think one of the
mistakes that westinghouse and maybe
other companies made 40 years ago was we
did have a we started with a standard
design but then due to customer
requirements or customer requests we
modified that design and so you ended up
building in many cases several
first-of-a-kind plants and it's very
difficult to from an economic
perspective for the utility be
successful for the vendor to be
successful if you're building
first-of-a-kind plants so you know this
time around you know we are sticking
with with the ap1000 design we are
saying this is the plant that we know
how to build we know the technology it
is a safe design when you start talking
about standardizing across you know
different different companies
you know globally I think that becomes a
larger challenge very problematic not
saying it couldn't be done but that's a
significant challenge and just so you
know it advanced reactors the Department
of Energy is working with the NRC with
federal funding to start the development
of general general design criteria for
your advanced system so looking at
sodium fast reactors and high
temperature gas reactors it's at least
there's a start it's it's not sufficient
but it's a start which aims is
standardizing the safety of you not the
designs themselves well but it but the
general design criteria will drop will
help inform the design process right
okay and and so when when you build
Westinghouse reactors in various
countries are though do those reactors
look very similar from between China and
the US for example or and does the look
does the local policy of each country
affect the way the reactor is building
looks I would say it's very difficult to
absolutely build the same plant in
different countries there there are
different requirements in each of the
countries but I would say we are doing a
much better job of managing those
changes in keeping the base plant design
the you know how the safety systems
operated the same across the you know
whether it's in China or here in the US
it's it's you know with with different
regulatory requirements with different
customer requirements it's it's I won't
say impossible but it's very difficult
to build the the same plant in two
different countries but we we are doing
a much better job and we have processes
in place to make sure that the design
doesn't change unless it's absolutely
necessary can you speak to the the
impact of of energy policies in various
countries on deploying to globally well
I i think you know and this has been
stated before the the lack of a clear
energy policy in the US has certainly
hurt us there are other countries that
are far ahead of us
with understanding how they're you know
what their energy policy is what they're
committing to and if you look at France
you know if you look at China India is
beginning to develop their energy policy
they are far far ahead of us mark do you
want to comment on that question and so
I don't really have much dad just just a
a brief comment on the issue of policy
certainly the lack of an energy policy
in the US has crippled to all energy
source potentials so that's a problem
but what for me would be a great help is
if the nuclear community and national
labs would look ahead 50 years and given
the carbon cycle and the clock that's
ticking and just tell us what's possible
50 years from now how much electricity
can be generated by nuclear power how
many plants can be built and what will
be the reduction in co2 emissions that
results with that information one could
then look at the waste problem at the
proliferation issues and say well that's
worth it or not and and so my drum that
I keep beating is we're on a pretty
tight schedule we have limited resources
we're already paying quite a lot for our
nuclear legacy if you look at the do a
budget and so we have to be quick and
shrewd and the allocation of resources
and they allocation has to have an
impact over the next 50 60 years so a
switching switching topics slightly to
non-proliferation is does
non-proliferation face new challenges or
is it helped by this concept of a
nuclear Renaissance
could I defer to mark I would argue
again I don't like Renaissance the
global expansion when you have more and
more nations developing nuclear
technology for peaceful uses for
generate electricity that that does
raise the need to deal with a
non-proliferation issue as each nation
enters into that world so does it does
it make me nervous no but it certainly
expands the problem to having to think
about just that many more that many more
actors there's policy frameworks in
place to deal with that
non-proliferation treating other policy
frameworks and I think and I think as
long as a nation and arisen to that is
willing to be transparent it's something
that we can do and we can do it we can
do it well and we can do it securely but
yes I mean but that's why the u.s. that
gets back to why the United States and
other nuclear energy states today need
to be involved it needs to be a global
conversation so I would say it's less
it's more policy and less technical that
solves the problem but they have the
sovereign right to use them to use it to
generate electricity and so we need to
we need to recognize that and work
within that framework and in a sense
they're there to sites the problem one
is the new entrant countries that are
developing new technology that have
small fleets and the other the growth of
fleeting existing in existing countries
and that that has to go hand in hand I I
presume correct do you think that
there's enough enough cooperation and
among the different countries in
supporting the new entrant the new
entrance to the nuclear industry I would
say yes I mean with with the exception
of a few the new entrants have been very
are coming to the table cooperatively
and having in having productive
discussions the IAEA has a International
Atomic Energy Agency has a key key role
and
in assuring that and all the country's
support the IAEA so I would say yes you
could argued as the IAEA have enough
resources that we could have that
discussion but there's mechanisms
organizations and policies that exists
again with a few exceptions the new
entrants are I think that a from a
policy perspective playing well Jim from
the industry perspective have have you
looked at deploying a p1 thousands in
new entrant countries I absolutely you
know we're looking across Europe and
across Asia you know and when you say
new entrants I assume you're talking
about emerging type type countries and
the challenge there is you know from an
infrastructure standpoint these are
these are large plants so do they have
the infrastructure from a supply chain
from distribution of electricity so
there are there are challenges that you
have in emerging markets that you don't
have in in the more developed in the
more developed countries and countries
that have existing nuclear capacity so
we're working with those countries but
there are there are other issues that
you need to overcome if if you're going
to build nuclear in an emerging country
if I could that raises I didn't mention
this but it's important as these as
these countries emerging countries come
into play they have to develop the let's
call it the infrastructure to be able to
not only build and operate these
machines but also regulate the Machine
regulate the reactors and so that the I
don't want to understate the importance
of developing that infrastructure could
I just comment on the proliferation
issue that for me the the challenge is
how quickly the international terrain
can change United States and Russia hold
ninety percent of the physical material
that might find its way into weapons
today the relation between United States
and Russia I would say is at an all-time
low in terms of cooperating on nuclear
issues particularly securing fissile
material as we see
nuclear power spread to countries like
Vietnam which have essentially no
nuclear infrastructure one can easily
imagine political changes in these
countries so suddenly changing what was
a good idea to being a very bad idea and
so we have to think ahead about these
issues can we also take questions
through the mic from the audience Sarah
Mike so speaking as a citizen as we all
are concerned about climate change I
mean I can imagine that we could have a
passively safe fission reactor and given
the option of you know five to ten
meters of sea level rise of a nuclear
waste dump in my backyard I could even
contemplate no nuclear waste dump but as
we read the newspapers and look at the
what's happening in Iran and other
places around the world and we also
contemplate the expansion of nuclear
power that are projected to meet the
needs of the of the world in 2100
there's going to be an enormous
expansion of nuclear power what we're
contemplating at the same time a move to
breeder reactors that will generate
fissile material and I've seen
projections for up to 500,000 sq SQ is
what it takes to make a nuclear bomb so
500,000 excuse in the world to generate
three tyler watts of electricity from
nuclear power stations and that seems to
be a really scary prospect i mean that
you could even argue it's kind of
suicidal so of all the issues of fission
power to be the proliferation in a
dangerous world that we live in if you
look and you know the front pages of
newspaper that seems to me the biggest
obstacle to to really
having fishing shoulder a large fraction
of the budget of you that the energy
that the world needs just say that comes
from a fusion physicist we'll be talking
later this afternoon I guess I would
just make the comment just to clarify
the current state there's the machines
that are being built or not breeder
reactors just to be just so everybody's
clear on that there are advanced designs
that could that could breed but they can
also burn so actually the designs we're
developing in the US or more focused on
burning versus breeding just to be just
to be clear I mean I take your point but
I mean you've got this you've got a deal
you've got to balance all of these
challenges and decide what's the right
future if you if you if you all are
successful at Princeton and we can have
fusion in 50 years that's fantastic but
but this has got to be an option but but
I just add to what Mark said light water
reactors around the world or creating 70
to 90 metric tons of plutonium each year
right so long so I think this ties into
to fuel supply security of fuel supply
in various countries perhaps Jim you
want to comment on the on fuel supply
and fuel supply I I think a security of
fuel supply maybe one of the other
panelists is uh as more background in
that area fuels right so I'll be a
geologist for a moment a few years ago I
asked myself the question do we have
enough uranium and my answer will fall
in the range of the answer is given by
others but if globally we increased
nuclear power energy production by a
factor of two or three present and
very certain expected resources would
sustain us for about a hundred years
well there's the question of global
availability and also the distribution
of resources do we have a similar
political situation as we have with with
hydrocarbons where the deposits are
concentrated in certain areas and
perhaps in a distant future we can we
can envision some inequities in the fuel
supply well they're inequities in this
case in the eyes of the beholder in
North America if we include the Canadian
deposits their substantial for us the
world's major producer at the moment i
think is kazakhstan new developments in
technology mainly in situ leaching will
certainly make lower grade deposits
economic in the future so I I you know
the major nuclear countries well I
shouldn't say more that's speculation
what Jim Brennan showed is a timeline
for ap1000 and if you started the
conceptual to first fuel load it's 30
years walking through testing design
licensing etc now let me say that can be
accelerated by some amount some small
amount how can any other technology
really contribute to reducing greenhouse
gases over the time periods people think
it needs to be impacted other than light
water reactors if I can if I can just
preface maybe some of what we just said
your ear correct from 1985 to 2015 you
know
that that design evolved as we went also
in the 80s 90s third there was not a
large demand for new nuclear so I think
that also played a role in the timetable
speaking to how long it will take from a
new reactor designed to actual fuel load
and plants start up so it is it is a
long process but I think there are other
market factors that added that up to to
make it 30 years see you're just going
to take the bait so III thought there
isn't anyone there isn't one that can
actually do it right I mean you
basically said that that I mean that
it's too late already for climate change
its at some level so light water
reactors have to be key for the new
builds now III would maintain that maybe
we build light water reactors forever
for all intensive purposes but I would
maintain we should be the advanced
designs will come into play down the
road but it's those will be too late to
address this this urgency for climate
change that we're talking about
immediate urgency I think it's also a
question of innovation and is there room
for a lot more innovation in in nuclear
technology and can we change that
timeline is due the new technologies
change that development timeline do
small modular reactors change that
development timeline do advanced reactor
exchange that perhaps if we have enough
smart people aren't working on it
perhaps like that's possible so I think
we need to wrap up I'll ask each of the
panel members to just give us a
one-minute concluding remark on the
topic of what what actions can the
audience take to shape the direction of
of the nuclear renaissance of the
nuclear technology growth that we see on
the horizon rad would you like would you
like to start not really i'd rather be a
third but in terms of what the audience
can do
and in the vein of today's meeting I
think we need people to look very
carefully at the way we evaluate risk
and options risk isn't only just how
many people you kill there are other
parameters and I think if new minds and
approaches could come into play we could
evaluate energy-producing systems in
terms of environmental impact a broader
set of measures rather than just saying
no one died at Three Mile Island you
know i'm not against nuclear but i can
tell you a lot of this bumper sticker
phrases they aren't working any longer
we need a more sophisticated way of
making the case i agree i think that we
need to continue the conversation in a
broader context of all of the parameters
involved in the various energy
alternatives and and i think that we
need to focus a little bit more on what
we think should happen and to put a
concerted effort in that direction as
opposed to what what will happen because
there's a lot of uncertainty around what
will happen what is the future of
nuclear let's not focus on that let's
focus on what should happen and and just
put a concerted effort in that direction
and make it at making it happen more two
more young people coming into fields
like nuclear engineering and other areas
engineering and science that are helping
us develop the energy source of the
future we need more and more that also
fresh ideas and enthusiasm at this
science policy Nexus I think is really
is really key and this Institute's like
this or what this that's what this is
about so the universities need to really
I think step up and develop and be more
proactive on that
I think forms like this are a great
benefit to talk about the the benefits
and the risks of nuclear energy I think
we all have a responsibility to educate
ourselves on the different energy mixes
and the benefits and the risks and also
educate those that that we work with
that that we know there's there's a lot
of still misconceptions this technology
is is really a 50 year old technology
and there's there's really a lot of
misconceptions that still exists about
the benefits and the rest of this
technology so education I think is a key
component